does consciousness die with the body
and is meaning doomed like the universe
well i don't know
i would say i mean
we don't understand consciousness we
don't really understand its place in the
cosmos let's say but i'm not qualified
to answer such questions
i would say though that you know no one
stops listening to a symphony because
they know it's going to end
and so i think in some sense our proper
task is to find the meaning within the
finite when i had clinical clients who
were
consumed with such questions
because you know you can pick a time
frame of evaluation that makes all your
efforts futile right well the sun is
going to envelop the earth i think it's
four billion years so like get ready
it's like well what's the point of
stopping this baby from crying when the
sun is going to envelop the earth and
for well yeah you all laugh right but
but that laughter you see that's a sign
of wisdom
you know that's preposterous
why
i mean that's the existential question
right it's like well if all
if we're all doomed to ashes and decay
why do anything well i used the baby
crying for a reason
i mean who in the world is going to use
that argument to not feed their baby
well why feed that thing in four billion
years the sun's going to develop the
earth it's like wrong time frame folks
and so what i would say and i did say to
my clinical clients if you're adopting a
time frame that makes what you're doing
appear trivial
the problem isn't necessarily what
you're doing although it might be and
you have to ask yourself that question
because perhaps you are engaging in
something that's more trivial than you
should be the problem is that your
mind which is capable of leaping across
evaluative frameworks has picked a time
frame inappropriate for the task so quit
doing that instead you could say well
why don't you practice adopting the time
frame that imbues your
properly oriented action with the
deepest possible apprehended meaning and
why would you not think that the fact
that that meaning manifests itself with
the proper choice of time frame why
wouldn't you accept the fact that's
indication of a valid choice it
certainly feels like it you know what
you know what it's like you get engaged
in something a deep conversation a piece
of music a piece of art something you
love doing someone you love being with
you get engaged in that you lose your
sense of temporality and you don't pop
out of it and think oh my god i wish i
would use the time frame that made
everything irrelevant because of my you
know cognitive brilliance you think hey
we could do that some more like how
about all the time
and that's that's a good goal it's like
yeah how about that all the time
and then you've got time right when
you're engaged like that and i would say
that's a profound
neurophysiological signal that you're in
the right place at the right time right
because it's accompanied by a sense of
deep well-being and that's literally an
antidote to suffering i mean that
literally it's
with many of my clients who were
suffering
what we would strive to do was not so
much
make them happy because sometimes that
was impossible they were so
crippled in in so many ways often
physically and in pain but something
meaningful
that would keep them going
and keep them from straying
and keep them from thinking
homicidal and genocidal thoughts all of
that
and meaning that's the antidote to
suffering and the question is well how's
that best to be found well that's an
empirical question you have to you have
to look in your own life and see where
meaning glimmers and then pursue that
right
that's what harry potter is doing by the
way when he's chasing the snitch
i just
thought i'd let you know
and
you know you win the game if you catch
that thing
well that's not exactly right you get
100 points but you know it'll do
so another question
how about you
hi thank you very much for the lecture
um you talked a lot about me you talked
a lot about meaning um both from
perception and in music and art
what do you mean by meaning what is
meaning and
where where is its source
meaning is implication for action or for
reorganization of the perceptual frames
that frame
action so there is
and is that is that the sole aim of what
you is that what you find in art and
music
yes in complex ways i mean in in music
you find this demand that the music lays
upon you to orient yourself in
relationship to this harmonious
interplay of patterns
and you might say well why is that
meaningful when that's a good question
well it's because you're acting out
something like
the adaptation of your
soul to the structures of reality itself
now it's done very abstractly because
the patterns of music are not precisely
the actual patterns of the world right
they're abstractions but it's play and
representation and it's art
and so you're acting out the process of
optimal adaptation at a very high level
when you think what people are doing
imagine a viennese waltz you know so you
have this unbelievably well trained
orchestra they're all emitting patterns
like mad and they're playing while
they're doing that putting little twists
on the patterns so that they're a little
novel a little interesting even if
you've heard the music many times you
have the conductor who's keeping all
these specialized subsections operating
in harmony and then you have the couples
dancing and they're trained to do that
but they're cutting the rug you know in
the same way they they have their moves
and they're trying to impress each other
and there's a mating aspect of that and
they're all doing that harmoniously and
it's a complete vision of a ordered
society right from the subatomic realm
let's say all the way up to the cosmic
realm that's all taking place in the
dance and people don't know that but
well they do know it too you know and
they know it in that they're acting it
out
and there isn't anything in some sense
that you know more deeply or believe
more deeply than that which you act out
and you're not smart enough to
understand the full totality of your
actions
i mean we're not transparent to
ourselves we act out all sorts of things
that are
stunningly
brilliant without realizing it and it
takes in some sense it takes often
untold centuries for us to figure out
what we were doing and why
and so that happens to you you know in
your own life when you have a flash of
insight into your own behavior
that's why i was doing that it's like
while you were doing it why didn't you
know
well
you're complicated
you're really complicated and
certainly not transparent to yourself
and so
i have a paper called three types of
meaning you could look that up if you
wanted a more like a more technical
answer but
the music
answer by example is a good one and i
think people can really relate to it
because
you know the only person you ever hears
who says well i don't really like music
is like no that's just a posture you
know you like music you just want to be
you know kind of interestingly different
and controversial and it's really
something right and it's also
interesting that music has this
non-propositional structure that's
completely opaque to rational
argumentation
you know i said i used to like to watch
uh punk rockers yeah especially the ones
who did mosh pit punk rock and you know
i went to a ramones concert once it was
quite comical i was on the second floor
ah so loud i couldn't like couldn't hear
for three days after this concert
because it was pretty little theater we
sat about 800 people and they had their
stadium speakers in there it was like
sonic wall of sound and we were above
this mosh pit and there was all these
like nihilistic punk rockers down there
smashing into each other and throwing
themselves off the stage and i thought
for all this talk of nihilism there you
are dancing to the harmonious patterns
of life it's like you know smash this
state and all of that it's like
that's that will groove to that yeah
it's very comical so even among the most
the most propositionally nihilistic
they still fall in love with music it
might be harsh and grating to some ears
but
you start where you can and you know i
like the ramone so that was fine with me
so maybe yes